I think that there's
an element in which
the artist and the lover in love
share similar characteristics
and dispositions.
There is a willingness
to surrender.
There is a willingness to
give one's self to some higher
meanings.
There is something to be said
for a different kind of truth,
for subjectivity, for
the truth as it plays out
in your own head.
I mean, science
has been phenomenal
at empirical investigations,
at deconstructing the world
into little bits and pieces and
isolating the properties that
constitute reality.
That is all wonderful.
But as Werner Herzog says,
there's another kind of truth.
It is ecstatic truth.
It's a risk.
The artist has to
take that risk.
He has to put himself in
that state of heightened
vulnerability.
He has to disarm himself.
Freeman Dyson talks
about a new age of wonder
in which literally a new
generation of artists
will be writing genomes
with the fluency
that Blake and
Byron wrote verses.
How might these
technological instruments
empower the artist,
empower the imagination?
We try to smash our
sense of separateness
in temples of fragmentation in
a form of electronic Buddhism,
with throbbing bass beats
temporarily dissolving the self
and allowing us to
merge with the other.
When we have sex,
like Kama Sutra,
people talk about
blending into one another,
becoming one another,
entering the subjective head
space of the other.
This is a wonderful idea.
It reflects Richard Holmes's
book, The Age of Wonder,
where he talks about
the 17th century
where the artist
and the scientist
were friends, where the
astronomers were poets.
And then he talked
about the importance
of sort of interpretation,
subjective experience.
Although people in many
ways are afraid of that,
they're afraid of letting go of
their individuated self, when
you pop out the other
side, it was the best thing
you ever did, ultimately.
Those things we
fear the most end
up being the greatest therapies.
Life really does begin at the
edge of your comfort zone,
to take that leap, fall
in love, or die trying.